[Music]
kazuki takahashi the yugioh creator
manga comic creator found dead in the
sea at age 60. wow so sad wow they
figure out like what he was doing out
there in the sea isn't he just a copy or
though
a copy or of isn't he just a copycat
of a pokemon he's a tracer no no no i
think digimon's more of a copycat of
pokemon wait how's yugioh not a copy of
the pokemons yeah did you read the
original comics no i didn't know i did
cool
don't you come tell me about it yeah oh
maybe i will maybe we'll duel with it
he just starts
on the chord
what's going on
i put my card down then you're [ __ ]
shocked yeah i got a hollow foil bro you
made my trap card good yeah i gotta
attack 90 hollow foiled [ __ ]
attack 90 holofoil yup [ __ ] did you
guys actually play pokemon yu-gi-oh
i've done i've done magic before i
remember when i was a kid i played
yugioh once with a friend and i did the
whole card game thing and as soon as i
did that [ __ ] i was like i'm selling
these [ __ ] cards why it's not fun i
just i didn't get it i was like that's
what i thought
i was like the [ __ ] is this i was like
i was like i can't do this is it better
than connect four magic was cool no
connect four is pretty fun connect four
is six [ __ ] connects with everybody
yeah connect four is like engaging with
this you put the card down then
everyone's gotta figure out what the
math is yeah yeah and i'm gonna subtract
the whole time dude yeah why i do a long
hand like hey did you put your energy
card down i'm like i'm like why are we
doing this why what the [ __ ] is an
energy card yeah i always was bummed
about those i was like why are these
bananas so boring the 60 year old died
after an apparent snorkeling trip oh
he's only 60. yeah near the southern
he's a healthy boy huh he was found off
the coast wearing an underwater mask
snorkel and fins
uh and they are now currently
investigating the case as both um a
possible accident or crime have you
heard of [ __ ] japanese atlantis
what's that no what is that the coast of
okinawa they found this pyramid-like
structure underground it's [ __ ] crazy
dude it looks like a platform and [ __ ]
and it looks like there's stairs and all
that stuff do you think he was looking
for japanese atlantis i think he was
yeah he was looking for he was on a
quest
for japanese atlantis he was found off
the coast of carlsbad
yeah
stuck in the triangle bro yeah yeah the
bermuda one he got warped in the
triangle that's it's the korea triangle
it's the other side isn't that [ __ ]
hella far from japan yeah but that's
what it's starting when you get in the
portal from the triangle dude your
[ __ ] spits you out back in japan that
is pretty crazy slapping amelia earhart
they found her body in [ __ ] i don't
know where she's at either
they found her upside down she's still
the same age she went in the bermuda
triangle and then they found her upside
down
you explain it you explain it it's like
denzel
[ __ ] flight or whatever it's called
he went through the bermuda triangle in
flight yep that was she was upside down
that's what happened
crazy this guy is [ __ ] active at 60.
strong japanese jeans men that's what
they do yeah that's that's my favorite
thing he's gonna be snorkeling all
across the [ __ ] world why do people
smoke will not scuba dive because
snorkeling you can go deep for nothing
yeah but then you gotta get certified
for scuba diving yeah i know because i
had to do that
are you paddy certified i am actually
yeah i know damn swanson come talk about
yeah
why was he alone that's the real
question like they just found this guy
they go oh [ __ ] he's dead and they go
let's try to figure out who this person
is and they go you're not going to
believe who this person is he's the
master yu-gi-oh might be an adventurous
mofo by himself maybe he was sad like
everybody else in japan
japanese men are often very solitary
japanese people in general could be very
solitary
dude there's this whole solitaire's a
sick game there's a whole phenomenon
that's happening right now i think it
was like
now a hundred thousand plus people of
dude like people that just stay in their
rooms yeah pico morries right yep yeah
what are they called piko norway are
they called world of warcraft players
they're basically that basically but
they just have these crazy like um
social anxieties and stuff and so they
can't function in the real world like
they're just like literally stuck in the
room the entire social anxiety is a
[ __ ] sham i was on a plane with this
dude yesterday
coming to jk right i was on a plane
and this dude it was so odd he had his
so he had his own chair next to him
and he's just hunched over with an ipad
watching like ravenously watching friday
night lights
like like like a madness is he is he
he's like watching it like [ __ ] like
is he getting into it he's just like
yeah yeah i'm not kidding either like
this is like he so he's booby miles or
the tv show the tv show and
so he's on it he's on his phone like
texting somebody and he's like he's like
watching friday lights
i've never seen anything like this in my
life people love that show people
apparently i didn't know they loved the
show this morning he was so hyped about
it you just had to look over been like
damn what's so hype oh you're just
watching that on his phone he's like
how old was that
i don't know it's like 30. he's like
touchdown dude they score he's watching
he's watching friday night lights like
he's going to eat the screen
like it's the [ __ ] most delicious
hearty show what if he was tripping
balls at that point he was like oh yeah
rolling or something
that sounds like a drug feature right
here don't watch five night lights is
all i gotta say that [ __ ] sexy [ __ ]
you up it's a it's a gateway drug
worse than fentanyl then we're leaving
the plane and i actually took video of
this [ __ ] because he's walking
while watching friday night life
because he literally can't stop i will
show you the video he can't [ __ ] stop
but in your head you're like i gotta
[ __ ] watch this goddamn show i'm not
gonna check out this [ __ ] show not
just that but i was like dude there's
there's people playing basketball and
wheelchairs on friday night lights i was
like that is a show i did not know about
truly because about football that's what
i'm saying the scene i saw i was like
why are people wearing jerseys in
wheelchairs playing basketball
how do you know it's friday night lights
because it said right now lights on the
thing oh okay oh definitely friday night
lights because he was he was watching
like this
yeah
boys you guys gotta check out
you guys should take the challenge watch
friday let's see if it doesn't take over
your whole [ __ ] life we should all
watch it together we should try and ruin
our [ __ ] lives did you guys get into
like pokemon yu-gi-oh all that stuff
like nuts like i got a pokemon i was in
[ __ ] like sixth or seventh grade at
the time and you would watch that as
like the tv show
holiday right now 36
same same same thing a couple years
younger than me i had two little
brothers who were
shocked because i had well my nephew's
10 years younger than me and he was in
it like he was [ __ ] in and i i i
thought i just passed that age me too i
don't think i ever got into it because i
was just right at that cusp i wasn't
like fourth wait were you in junior high
yeah that age got this big because if
we're in high school see if we're in
high school and they're in junior high
that's a big age gap yeah i was hyped up
that [ __ ] too i was hyped on it well
because my little brothers were really
into it so that's how i started on it
but then yeah dude once i was at school
i've talked about this before but once i
was in school and i had a binder of
pokemon cards and this [ __ ] looked at me
she's like steve you like pokemon cards
i was like not anymore i'm [ __ ]
throwing this [ __ ] away in the garbage
so
ninth grade sixth grade oh junior high
yeah i was like i'm out of this [ __ ]
stupid hobby the only time i really got
in like a near physical altercation with
my cousin ever in my entire life is when
i accidentally stepped on his venosaur
hologram first edition card
why is he leaving how much is that worth
probably three grand now now but like at
the time it was just another [ __ ]
card nobody knew that's probably worth a
million tim back then it was i had that
one i i stepped on this [ __ ] card and
then like this will like bolted out my
house like pissed off and i tried to go
again put me in a
headlock wow so you you put you you're
in the front lawn just i was trying to
fight you know to me i was like i'm
sorry about your venusaur you know what
i mean i knew that i had done it so cute
that you chased after him too that
you're like i need to apologize do you
ever get in the heat of the moment and
one thing leads to another yeah let me
start making it my friend's house he had
like a whole lego world built right oh
no like that and then he wasn't home yet
and i was just waiting for him to come
home and then i was just like playing
like [ __ ] cars with like the legos
and then i just i think my imagination
just took over and then [ __ ] these
things they were beefing and i just
destroyed this whole [ __ ] because i
smashed them all together right wait the
legos were beefing with each other was
in my mind i was playing i was like oh
[ __ ] this guy kills him this guy's head
flies off and he shoots at the [ __ ]
tower this tower breaks so i'm just you
know i have a question dismantling were
you watching friday night lines
all right so i did all that
and then afterwards this one i calm down
and i'm like oh [ __ ] he's gonna [ __ ]
kill me and then uh he didn't come home
yet i forgot what happened
you don't remember
that's what it's like because it's out
of his own imagination like it's not
just legos where he builds off a box it
was from his brain right
i leave and then i had one like remote
control car there i forgot why i had to
like i don't know piano practice and
[ __ ] and then i i leave and i had a
remote control car there uh when i came
back um he was bawling his eyes out god
crushed his toys and then my [ __ ] was
[ __ ] smashed to pieces but i felt
like i deserved it oh he [ __ ] up your
remote control club my [ __ ] just
slammed it because you're so [ __ ]
pissed i just felt so bad i'm like dude
you know like sometimes legos was like a
drug it just goes one thing you know
that thing when you play with legos
bart what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
that's so not common and nobody can
relate to you
don't get this guy [ __ ] legos dude
like you ever get carried
one thing leads to another and you've
just committed murder and you're like oh
the legos
he's like you guys know how it is that's
playing legos so the cops are like
[ __ ] like
he's like
don't don't ever show me connects that's
all i gotta say
don't you ever [ __ ] show me those
things you you wait to see oh you guys
think i'm a madman huh oh wait something
leads to another man
[Music]